the common for the electrical ended up
shorting out losing connection and so
the studio lights don't work because of
it all the wires are now behind drywall
which makes it very difficult to figure
out where it goes and where it shorted
out at well I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to heat up the wire inside the
wall hopefully when it heats up wherever
the wire touches or wherever it gets
close enough the drywall should emanate
Heat hopefully this is a diagnostic
thing for us to try to figure out where
this wire is and we're charting it's a
CPU fan CPU heatsink exactly like the
one I made and it's even got like a fan
down here so it's like it's literally
what I made with a nice fancy case and I
like their led more because mine's a
square this one's a circle so it's like
better and apparently this has been
measured perfectly to hit all the size
of this oh yeah no no like make up her
this is this is well engineered but it
is really funny how it is a CPU cooler
inside of it every our skin even really
good for export going on for ninety nine
thousand
there's no way to match that number
today
oh just today but I'm not reading I'm
also drafting I'm taking an employment
contract that I think is good and I'm
trying to infuse this stock document
into it yeah that's what's happening to
him so I got another funnel tool from
FLIR I think it's called an electric pen
what it is is a non-contact voltage
indicator we just turn onto high
sensitivity mode you can see that right
now it's kind of picking up some random
stuff once I put close to the wall you
can see that it's like going crazy back
up it stops and what that means is
there's lines inside this wall that have
power or AC power to them a little
sensitivity oh they're right there I can
tell that there's wires right behind the
wall so I'm going to use this tool to
take the common that we know runs over
to here and we're going to turn off all
other electricity and hook that common
into the hot making it have electricity
then we can use this tool to go along
the wall where we know it's running and
see where the current stops running and
since it's the only thing that's on
it'll stop working the second that the
wire isn't connected anymore hopefully
figure out exactly where that spot is
Oh
so everyone's away at VidCon Gabe and I
are here by ourselves today and tomorrow
kind of holding down the fort working
I'm gonna FaceTime them well back to
work late